we missed new rockstars 2x4 breakdown
but today we're gonna make sure we
continue with their two by five
breakdown because the
so katana was in it a whole bunch of
information revealed if you missed our
reaction make sure to check that out but
before we get into that
i did want to say mando occasionally has
to pay for things
so you imagine he has to keep some
currency in his
wallet from time to time right with
everything he's carrying could already
be so heavy
you know how wallets can be and that's
why today's video is sponsored by the
ridge
wallet i really love the hell out of
these things despite my stupid joke
about
denjarin where he's in a damn wallet um
if only they came in vescar
that was good i should have gone with
that anyway listen
guys i really do love this wallet it has
made my life
so much easier when i go running i don't
have to worry about my pants falling
that's the biggest change
check this out the ridge offers rfid
blocking
sleek minimal design aluminum titanium
carbon fiber thirty thousand five star
reviews free shipping and returns
worldwide it is perfect for christmas
season
i'm definitely getting my friend brandon
this wallet i hope he doesn't watch this
video
if you wanna get yourselves a ridge
wallet use promo code reject nation to
save yourself 10
on your order and just go to ridge.com
reject nation
promo code reject nation rejection
welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of the
mandalorian season 2 episode 5 chapter
13
the jedi perhaps the most crucial
episode of the series since it's
tell me what tython is tell me
her quest to find granada here
i'm the child we have been calling yoda
that name being
the grogu grogo and i can feel each
other's thoughts it's gregory
which i assume by now that you know and
already have an opinion about that right
another video breaking down grogu's
timeline
they're like it's not baby yoda guys
found him in the mailing series premiere
and tommy and i went
into it further in wikileaks but in this
episode i am going to go through this
episode frame by fray to scrutinize
each shot of the episode not just for
the many star wars easter eggs and
tie-ins but for the fascinating craft
details that we will make the show put
into
it and yeah before i begin the shirt i
am wearing is our this is the way
shirt it is available for a limited time
only in our official merch store new
rockstars merch i think i'm gonna get
that shirt
knocked out i think i'm gonna get that
shirt
[Music]
i am buying that about back in chapter
shirt
though instead of the lush rivendell i
kind of expected we instead get a
charred mordor landscape which in our
rookie lakes after show i interpreted as
a symbolic reflection of the dead
jedi dogma that ahsoka and groho should
the smokey fog illuminates with the twin
white blades
of ahsoka tano played in flawless
cosplay by rosario dawson
maybe sniff's snips could have been a
bit longer because she's older but oh
well she looks just like her otherwise
bravo in the background asukitano was
introduced back in clone wars and
against apprentice and friend who later
gets falsely accused for a crime by the
jedi order and even after her name is
cleared she walks from that order
and in the final season of clone wars
again earlier this year she helped poke
a tan liberate mandalore
666 came out she was forced to break
with her beloved clone of her unit
ahsoka is close that's a great four
partner fantastic four partners
with these two white lightsabers that
she actually got from inquisitors
inquisitors were former jedi dragged
over to the dark side and tasked with
hunting down run away is that bearish
ends with ahsoka joining sabine
to seek out ezra bridger who had
previously zipped away to some unknown
destination via hyperspace whales
along with thrawn ahsoka's lightsaber
action here is so well created
[Music]
good call and it's awesome to see how
creative she gets with these sabers
she slices a trunk and then she cleaves
out a whole piece that she can use to
take a guy out yeah
so it's not just saber against enemies
she uses her whole
surroundings the kaladin magistrate is
morgan elsbeth played by diana lee out
of santo i just learned this in the
comments on our last one
and goddaughter
i was like hell yeah this warrior
don't recognize her lieutenant lang
played by michael bean star of
terminator and aliens
although i wish he had a bigger role in
the show that's what we said
this episode is titled the jedi for
ahsoka i was something the title could
have been like plural
and or also referring to the child but
translations from other languages show
how they use the feminine article for
the in this case
as mando and the child approach they
can't go there's a spherical knob at the
end of the control stick the one that
the kid wanted in chapter three and that
amanda looked at and remembered that he
still loves his kid he made his true
active love to rescue him i
have a feeling grosgu's love of it might
go deeper than just like a mere kid
wanting a toy
maybe it reminds him of some part of his
past like i don't know it could have
been taken to the
mando is asked if he is part of the
bounty hunter guild to which he responds
last night which is interesting because
he kind of broke with the guild rules
back in that chapter three episode
though he hasn't
checked if he's still part of it and
he's also starting to bend the rules of
his own mandalorian code so he really
has no problem reuniting on this
agreement with the magistrate we're just
seeing how the only rule that remains
sacred of this character is his love for
the child and love yeah
walls these circular towers with their
flat conical roofs and within the city
walls there's all these peasants living
in squalor
with a sharp contrast to the inner
courtyard palace
serene beautiful a bubble of paradise a
classic wealth disparity that you see in
those kind of stories where the wealthy
elite landlords are
completely unaware of the problems of
the people serving underneath them and i
love how later the duel
plays out with a slow deliberate kendo
style fight choreography
a throwback to the slower sword play of
obi-wan and vader that george lucas
originally
based the whole jedi culture on the
imagery may also remind you of the final
duel and the quiet guard between the
people
yeah bill quinn tarantino is also a
lover of akira kurosawa and staged this
battle the same way a raging
melee height name to an ice cold
intimate face-off meanwhile the
western counterpart to samurai films the
western film genre inspires a duel
outside the courtyard between mando and
lang with a gunslinger showdown lifted
directly from the work of directors like
sergio leone essentially westerns and
samurai films are
parallel genres just from different
parts of the world both inspiring the
star wars say
more specifically spaghetti westerns
it's so amazing to see
both play such a big role in this
episode elsa keeps prisoners on display
in these public stocks with electric
fields
zapping them to reveal their skeletons
underneath similar to the zapping sith
lightning that we've seen before
and i believe hera was tortured with one
of these elizabeth feeds her fish and
her koi pond though
i'm pretty sure those aren't koi in
there notice grogu gives them a curious
look kind of like the frog eggs very
much into aquatic life just keeping
track of his amphibious origins as we
try to narrow them down elizabeth
reminds me
that the jedi are ancient enemies of
mandalore offering him as a reward for
killing ahsoka a pure vescar
spear capable of resisting lightsaber
strikes telling us that nando's armor
is modes away from some ahsoka hits but
also shedding some light on the ancient
jedi and mandalorians
now they were so evenly matched i love
the ping
the staff makes when he strikes it on
its gauntlet
yeah there's an almost
magical strength that you can hear in
there that justifies its ability to
repel a lightsaber hit as they venture
out to find ahsoka amazing easter egg
here the bird on the branch in the upper
left this owl
it's morocco right a hugely significant
spirit animal that follows ahsoka it is
the embodiment of the daughter one of
the
three mortis cosmic entities who
represents the light side of the force
the daughter gave her light to
save ahsoka and now she is represented
in this
[Music]
[Music]
snare mando but then he mentions about
katan sent him and she sees a child
and then our lives get so much better
next scene
in the light of the moon ahsoka and grow
who stare each other down and from this
non-verbal force
length she reveals his name in origin
grogo
he was raised at the jedi temple on
coruscant at the end of the clone wars
when the empire rose to power
he was hidden someone took him from the
temple
and i love how grub looks
yoda why is jedi master named yoda
[Music]
the john williams yoda theme playing
underneath ahsoka says some mystery
person took the child
from the jedi temple during order 66 in
yesterday's video i speculated that
could have been yeah
most of us assume to be dead based off
of a comic where vader fights seattle's
ghost
but there have been like other mentions
and things like jedi falling order that
suggests she might still be alive we'll
see
now it could have just been obi-wan
kenobi who did survey that temple in the
aftermath and this could definitely tie
in the upcoming kenobi series others
have suggested jocasta new the temple
librarian who did die
shortly after the events of revenge of
the sith but did have enough time to
save that kid if she could have
i'm also intrigued by the possibility of
mace windu who supposedly died
though nobody was ever found and there
is speculation that he could get a
future spin-off series if the theories
are true that grugu and anakin's
matching birth ears
mean they might be part of a dyad i
could see a scenario where grogu uses
his force healing powers to heal the
wounds on mace windu that were caused by
the counterpart anakin now the stark
birds
gave his way to completely green in the
area where ahsoka trains baby yoda an
interesting reflection of the
life force that these two jedi are about
to tap into ahsoka levitates a rock to
him echoing the way master yoda used
rocks to train luke on digabot
and she says this that's much fairer
than you
a direct callback to yoda's warning to
anakin and phantom menace
ahsoka fears that training the child
with vulnerable personal connections
will result in the same calamity as her
old friend anakin
who she calls heartbreakingly the best
of us ahsoka explains how else this
family was massacred during the clone
wars and that ellsworth used that anger
to plunder and destroy worlds to help
build the imperial starfleet but i don't
think that's her mo
now the fact that she calls thrawn her
master suggests to me that she and
thrawn might be building a
new starfleet that's separate from the
empire maybe an independent order of
thrawn
ahsoka and mando team um slices that
bell in half so notice how she
also slices the cardstock
87 droids an apparent upgrade from the
hk47 from nice to the republic
a look at also appears we saw one of
these last season and for many this
is another sign that ezra richard could
show up at some point they do
come from his home world but when ahsoka
confronts elsman in the courtyard i love
how we
don't see ahsoka arrive she's just
already standing there waiting for her
this showdown was inevitable a promise
delivered from that opening scene
surrender or face the consequences
when ahsoka ignites her right blade the
wind catches her robe on the ground
it's a nice detail of vfx meeting
practical to suggest the warmth of the
blade could have affected the airflow
there after a
thrilling duel ahsoka drops the big
question
where is your master where is grand
admiral throng
so aethron was one of the first big
things to come out of the star wars
expanding universe novels he was so
popular that dave maloney later brought
him into season three of rebels
originally thrawn was tasked with
leading the empire after its defeat and
battle of endor but rebels during the
galactic civil war he is pursuing the
crew of the ghost
yes he's last seen disappearing in
hyperspace with ezra so for ahsoka
finding thrawn means finding ezra
unless she already found them in these
past few years
and that perhaps ezra and sabine could
be dead
now ahsoka just oh that would suck so
thrawn is a
chiss he is a genius tactician skilled
hand-to-hand combatant which
might be why else that calls him quote
master i really do think or at least i
hope that he is now building his own
starfleet independent from the old guard
of the empire or palpatine
just because thrawn would be such a
cooler villain who embraces the spirit
of legends what people
love about star wars without getting
bogged down in that same old rebels
versus empire conflict that every
generation of star wars
is driven by ahsoka tells mando to take
grogu to
taithon and place him on his scene here
we go
here we go the new hope is that jedi
luke skywalker could sense that and
connect with these characters
maybe with a dh mark hamill or just a
hooded figure with animal's voice but
the
fear is that darker for sensitive
entities might intercept that cause
mice is like from star wars legends it
was originally the home to the jedi
order predecessor to the jedi order but
it was brought
into official canon in a force awakens
rpg and then a later novel python is
essentially one of the
sacred jedi sites along with okay okay
maybe the ruins where all of this
started in the final moments notice how
ahsoka and grogu exchange the subtlest
nod of respect
very similar to the nod that ahsoka
exchanged with elseville to me
this suggests an even deeper
understanding between the jedi than we
realize
maybe deeper thoughts and secrets in
guruku's mind that basilica chose not to
disclose command
i would say most likely absolutely
to try to keep himself and mando away
from ahsoka's beef withdrawn which is
probably gonna get real nasty and closer
to a path that will
intersect we'll definitely set up an
ahsoka show or a woman it's a hundred
percent
all the subtle details that i found this
episode but there is so much more to
talk about from
this one episode we're gonna be making
more videos about it in the meantime
subscribe to new do yourself a favor and
do it people
follow me rock stars thank you for
watching i have spoken
cool all right thank you senpai aaron
chat about a couple of these things yeah
those are some
fun ones to learn about the only real
easter egg i think i got right
the apple yeah morai yeah that was all i
saw i happened to catch that owl and i
was like i think that's moraine that's
about it and i think it's really cool
that if
you know i i don't know if dave filoni's
come out and said that if that is morai
indeed if it is i think that's a cool
subtle nod
to morai actually being there because i
remember when i watched clone wars
the finale i didn't know who that bird
was when
watching rebels it was like oh okay this
makes a lot more sense
now because rebels came out before the
final season the clown horse came out
they threw the bird in there i haven't
seen
any of rebels yet so to actually see the
bird there
uh makes you pay close attention we've
been watching over ahsoka this entire
time now so you you'd expect
morey to be there so i feel like it's
very likely that it's not just
an owl you know how that is no i caught
the owl and i was like cool an owl soon
i learned that that was an easter egg
but i do love
i thought this was like oddly kind of a
thoughtful breakdown and i like that uh
argument as to perhaps the appearance of
ezra bridger with the cats you know from
his homeworld and whatnot you know and i
like that they at least
showed one example of that you know sort
of hailing the appearance of an animal
or a spirit creature like that hailing
the appearance of a character
i don't like the idea that like the
theory of
that ahsoka tana may be seeking revenge
uh for the death of sabrine wren and
ezra bridger
unless of course you get like a ahsoka
tano spin-off show and it's not picking
up immediately from these events
and instead you start from that point
where they find ezra bridger their
legacy characters in star wars canon and
they're like the two most important
characters in rebels if they're just die
off screen and you don't acknowledge
that in like with live action i feel
like that would actually be pretty
upsetting and rather disappointing
there's kind of an argument to be made
for ezra bridger because he makes the
ultimate sacrifice at the end with
rebels even though
thrawn clearly is alive but i personally
don't think it would be wise for them to
go that route with both of them
dead off screen especially when you end
rebels with sabine
and ahsoka setting off on a mission to
fight
and then we just cut two later and
they're both dead and ahsoka wants her
veg i i'm not a big fan of that idea
that theory that's been floating around
but i really
loved what eric pointed out with a lot
of the technical call outs specifically
with the sound design with a lot of
these like hidden music cues i didn't
pick up on there's a moment where
actually
ahsoka's music i've heard plays at one
point and in the midst of being so
engrossed in the episode it actually
didn't catch it
uh when i first watched it and i need to
go back to the episode
and listen again for when that moment is
called i read about in some comments and
then even
in her comments i learned it this
morning want to shout out a person named
force
sensitive let me show it in the video he
was the first person to inform me of
this
said here's some trivia for you guys
this episode premiered on bruce lee's
80th birthday the actress playing the
magistrate is diane lee
in osanto daughter of bruce's best
friend
dan in a santo and she is also lee's
goddaughter
and i think that's really really cool i
mean i
i've see i think i've seen all of bruce
lee's movies it doesn't have a crap ton
of films but i think i've seen all them
to learn
this little fun fact and to have it come
out on his 80th birthday
i think it's glorious i i wish i knew
that going in because of course like
when you watch our reaction it's like
obviously we're picking up on all the
samurai tone and references and even in
its imagery
like that's very apparent western
influences like of course we're latching
on to all that
that right there is a really cool fun
fact that is a true like little easter
egg that does kind of enhance
and it's like eric said like had i had
known that i might have been kind of
giggling like
oh like master like yes yeah exactly
that was cool
and some people think that learning what
we learned about baby yoda is kind of
giving away
too much like that some people want a
little bit more mystery to him but
there's still so much to unpack in that
uh
yeah it's like you get some information
absolutely you get his name where he was
raised and then but you also set up the
door of okay who were his parents
is it yoda you know was it yoda
constantly preached about you know
having no attachments and stuff but did
he have an attachment was there a secret
romance that he had
who was the jedi that or who who put him
in hiding yeah who smuggled him out and
i
i liked the array of theories i mean
obviously based off that star wars
theory based windu video that's like
what i'm secretly hoping for but i also
feel like
i would be kind of excited if they took
this as an opportunity to bring in one
of those characters from the extended
canon that isn't
known on the live action screen yet like
that librarian jedi
you know who like got at least a little
bit of time after order 66 to kick some
ass before dying i could definitely see
some potential for uh yeah another
character to
to join the cast of course and one thing
i didn't talk about at all
which is something that i was constantly
saying what i what i'm hoping they bring
to life really well
and they did and for some reason i
didn't even bother to talk about it
during our review of the episode but
it's brought up here when he's breaking
down the fighting style of ahsoka tano
and i was like oh yeah that was one
thing i was always concerned about
was are they going to really capture
ahsoka's fighting style and they did
for the best they could do with live
action without having to go all prequel
flippy in the show
at least you know like well my mind
mainly goes to her fighting style in
clone wars she uses a lot of martial
arts moves beyond
her her lightsabers her dual lightsabers
she does a lot of flipping yes but she's
she's very flexible acrobatic it's a lot
of kicking she didn't solely rely on the
lightsabers and then
actually watching the episode back i'm
like oh she does do like a good amount
of flips actually
and i thought it was really cool they
met the right medium is the right
perfect balance to be able to go
well what's her fighting style and how
can we incorporate here to make you feel
a little bit more grounded when bringing
it to live action
i thought they completely succeeded and
i really wanted to shout that out
because that is something where they
could have been
very disappointing on and just made her
look like another
jedi you know yeah one i i remember you
talking in the review of the episode
about how her personality is a bit more
subdued but even as eric pointed out i
like that in the moments in battle where
they would let her kind of notice an
advantage she has and actually kind of
enjoy taking advantage of that to regain
the upper hand
especially like with that one droid
soldier who just kind of
decides to piece out yeah you know up to
top by the bell yeah she's got this
little smirk about her the entire time
and
uh i didn't really notice i didn't fully
latch onto
at the name of master yoda and baby yoda
looking up
well grogu looking up you cut to
ahsoka's reaction in that moment
and to me i'm like oh that's such an
endearing little smile moment when you
slap footage down like what new
rockstars did
and you see baby yoda i keep calling him
that groku looking up
you're like oh my god he is responding
directly to yoda yeah
yeah well yeah cause it became so
apparent to me every time he would make
eye contact with mando every time he
used his name and so yeah i
overlooked it at the time but i love
those thoughtful details that they
bothered to put in here because that's
the stuff that makes it worth
re-watching yes and also when it comes
to
accepting the mission i thought
he did a little bit of what's the word
i'm looking for lying by omission
yeah where you say certain words
to make it seem like you're
saying yes when you you technically
didn't say yes yeah but it sounds like
you're saying yes it's the heavy
implication that we have
some kind of connected arrangement here
and yeah i'm just not going to say all
of the terms of it out loud and
and acknowledge them so that you can
yeah come back and say that i broke it
because there was like it got a little
confusing to me it wasn't a big deal
uh but it was a tiny bit confusing
because you're like okay i
i was in the impression you accepted it
i think at one point didn't jaron does
say i didn't agree to anything when he's
back there he doesn't accept it because
he doesn't he doesn't accept the best
car spear at first because
he says uh uh i didn't finish the
mission i was like wait a minute did you
accept this mission or not
yeah yeah yeah and why am i so hung up
on this
yeah do you not want to take the spear
because you didn't do it for the mission
at all or is this some kind of yeah
hyper technicality like it wouldn't be
right i just i didn't do the job yeah
yeah i'm not anyway it's it's like we're
very important we're playing very big
semantics right
very important that we figure this out
close this plot hole now with tython
okay it's a good basics
i'm sure tython has a big thing you
could
there's a wikipedia about it i'm sure
there's something that you
you know like this is the basic
summation so that which what i love is
that make it digestible because i'm sure
if
i could dive in and really learn it all
but essentially it's like another
ancient historical jedi landmark
that they gotta go to and that's like
just follow the show you gotta get along
with that because
even breaking down ahsoka's backstory
here i'm like well there's so much more
than that but
this is the basics you need to know in
order to move forward
with the show yeah it's like the five
sentences you need to know to keep
moving forward and that's kind of how i
felt about tython
it was a fantastic episode one of if not
the best episode of the mandalorian
series so far and um yeah
yeah really i'm really glad i watched
some stuff this past year
guys subscribe to new rockstars if you
haven't done so already subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell
hey we'll catch you guys soon